[Music]
when you talk about
you know basically speeding up
processing of data
dealing with all that there are some
computers around that are already very
fast i mean simply using the internet on
a daily basis when you live in an area
with uh you know very strong broadband
internet
it's already very fast so when you say
it speeds it up exponentially what are
we talking about
we are talking about being able to
to bring that fast to an exponentially
faster time
duration that it needs to compute so
there is a recent example that was uh
demonstrated by the google team and
and collaborators and and they showed
that
by using 53 superconducting
qubits or qubits that were assembled to
to to operate in a quantum computer
they realized in 200 seconds
a complex operation that would take
10 000 years on a classical computer so
you can have an
idea of how fast it will be
and and this exponential decrease of the
time that is needed for computation
is actually received the name it is
called the quantum supremacy
now it is a very discussed and very
debated notion because
maybe there is a classical computer that
could be faster than
this 10 000 years that is uh reported by
google and indeed
when they published the paper this was
discussed a lot right is it really
quantum supremacy but the bottom line is
that for example
we will be able to factorize an integer
with a large number of digits
or to decide if a number is a prime or
not
in a time that is sufficiently short
that all the encryption
of data that is nowadays in place will
just be irrelevant
and so it means that when quantum
computer will become available
we will need to find new ways of
encrypting data
because otherwise not a single
communication
you talked about internet emails
but also more important when we use our
credit card
all this communication will become
completely
non-secure actually so every every
solution or every development
creates new challenges that quantum
physics or quantum mechanics hopefully
can help us
let us dream a little bit uh because we
have this uh
example before with the cloud passing
through the wall you already mentioned
that you and i we are
far too heavy uh in order to be able to
to have this kind of property to be able
to do that
but what about the idea of teleportation
uh about moving an object or maybe even
a being like in star trek beam me up
scotty
in the long term is that could this be
reality
it's not clear it can be a reality for a
macroscopic object but teleportation
again exploits the property of being in
a superposition of state so it's
it's the same property that is
exemplified by
the schrodinger cat and it has been
demonstrated and i will tell you in
which circumstances
and again at the atomic scale i mean so
when we go down in in lengths of length
and of mars and of time so the the idea
of teleportation is now to build special
specific superposition of state
for systems that are made at least of
two quantum particles
and this special uh superposition
allow to for example if
one of the particle that is part of the
system is localized at a
given place in time and the other
particle is localized
in another place
at a given time if one observer
makes a measurement on the particle that
is in region
a let's set it will
completely determine the measurement
will completely determine the
measurement that is
made on the particle
that is in region b so there is a
complete correlation
between the two state of the two
particles that compose the pair
of particles and this is called the
entanglement
property this is called to build an
entangled superposition of state
and it's really a consequences of the
superposition principle but
also on how a measurement is made
on a superposition of state in quantum
mechanics
and so teleportation can be
measured has been realized
on photons and it has been shown
by by a team of scientists at the nasa
that it was
possible to send two photons that are
the pair of particles in opposite
direction
and to to keep this special correlation
between the states of the photon in the
superposition this property of
entanglement
such that uh it survive over 44
kilometers so
if one receiver makes an ex
test the state of one of the photon at
zero in terms of kilometer
it determines the measurement that will
be made
40 kilometer 44 kilometer later by
the second observer this also has been
done
on over much longer distances but then
one has to use satellite so
the chinese team in uh just
last year in 2020 reported
that they were able using a low orbited
satellite where they generate
a pair of entangled photons so that have
this
particular superposition of state where
the state of the two photons are fully
correlated
they send them from from this law
orbiting satellite
in opposite direction and this
entanglement property was still
measurable
by two receivers that were distanced by
by one thousand five and
uh one thousand one hundred kilometer
let's not
exaggerate and so and this is possible
because here instead of traveling in an
optical
fiber the two photons travel in space
and they are subject to less
perturbation
just one more example because photon
uh a special particle but you can also
do it with electrons and so
there is a team uh in tu delft
that showed that you can measure this
entanglement property on a pair of
electron
on a distance on of one kilometer which
is
also a very big record uh
for then particle of the kind of
electrons so
teleportation it's not really
close to reality for very big object but
it is surely
exploited uh for quantum system
and it's a reality i mean it is measured
so let's let's talk about quantum
applications
uh because it would be interesting to
know how
uh quantum technology actually impacts
our
daily life quantum applications
are of two kinds well i can use quantum
mechanics and
and qubits uh to process tasks
uh that have to do for example
with uh deciding if uh an integer that
has a large number of digit
is a prime number or not or to decide
if the same kind of integers or with a
large number
of digit to to factor
it but there are another
range of applications that have to do by
with quantum simulations
and in quantum simulation what people
are trying to do is
to implement what feymine said
in his famous talk it is to use a
quantum computer to simulate
a quantum system and then
one can using a quantum computer
simulate very complex quantum system
like
molecules or even
biological system like protein
fragment of dna systems that are a very
complex assembly of
electron and nuclei that are interacting
what is known
in physics as a many-body problem
and their quantum computers will really
allow us to
understand better where quantum
phenomena
like interference effects so effect that
comes from the
wave particle nature of
of matter at the atomic scale and from
the fact that i can associate a
wavelength to
a particle so that leads to interference
and to
experimental manifestation of this wave
nature of
particle if this phenomena play a role
in biological process and for example
scientists are now
working to try to understand if
interference effect
are important for the efficiency of the
conversion
of the energy of the photon that are
emitted by the sun
to chemical energy in bones and this
is known as the photo synthesis
in biology another important aspect is
if coherence play a role in the
transmission
of electrical waves in synapses and this
has to do about
how our brain functions so quantum
computer could
explain or could help to understand
where the effect of quantum mechanics
occur in biological system and then we
can
use this understanding to improve
technology like for example
if we understand the role of
interference in energy conversion
from from photon to to chemical energy
or to electrical energy we will build
more
efficient photovoltaic cell which is
right now
a big issue in in view of the climate
change
so you see we have really two
ranges either we use quantum computers
to solve very complicated
mathematical problems of very
complicated logistic
problems so to to use the power of
quantum computer to
to process very quickly um
big data essentially or we use them
as simulators to better understand
the quantum mechanics of complex
many-body system
and this is this field this that i am
more interested in because
i am trying to in my research to
understand
coherence effect and the role of
interference
when a molecule evolve in time
let's just uh look ahead where do you
see quantum technology
in let's say 10 15 years from now i
think in
in closer than 10 15 years in five years
we will have a lot of quantum sensing
in every today life and
there is the the sensing that we can use
for biology for example which is very
important all the parts
that can be implemented to to better
detect
molecules so with higher precision
important for
for cancer important for understanding
how aging
occurs right in the population all kind
of
very important health issues
sensing is also very important for space
and we have developed this quantum
gravimeter
that allows to to measure gravitation
to better absorb the observe the earth
and then
we can get a better understanding of a
lot of processes that occurs
on earth and of course the climate
change
is a very important issue
on the longer term like 10 15 years
quantum computers
will become available and then
it will be a real revolution because
communication
will not be secured anymore because of
this
exponential increase in computational
capabilities that is
brought by quantum computers and so
we will have to encrypt our
communication using
also quantum technologies and to better
developed and bring to really technical
application quantum key distribution
protocols and
this will be an enormous change because
we
we use communication all the time
nowadays by various channels
another part is that in in my field
we will have the possibility to use
quantum computers to do
quantum simulation that is to simulate
the quantum properties of very complex
system
and this is also this will also be
a complete change because right now we
are very limited by the
possibilities and the capabilities of
classical computer and we cannot
probe or calculate the quantum nature of
very large systems very large molecules
assemblies of
atoms and quantum computer will allow us
to
to better understand and to go probably
to a certain quantum revolution
i would think well professor
thank you so much uh for your time for
taking the time to exploring
uh quantum technology the nature and the
application of quantum technology with
us and
now that we know that there'll even be a
a third quantum
revolution it's good that we had this
interview to catch up on what's already
been done
and i for one i'm uh going back to the
title at the beginning when we said
quantum technologies
imagination or reality a role for space
i would say in quantum logics
imagination and reality not
all reality and certainly a role for
space so thank you so much
and i'm very glad that we've got this
taped thank you for watching
and i'm sure you can review this video
in order to really understand
absolutely everything that was said it
was it's worth it
uh in the meantime obviously stay safe
[Music]
you